you represented the united states at
four olympics winning a bronze medal at
two of them
who
or what was the toughest match or moment
you had in those years maybe a moment
that defined you
that you remember as being particularly
defining in your career
i would say the the bronze medal match
in atlanta
in 96 because up to that moment the
united states team had not won a medal
had not fought for a medal in the games
we were on our home turf it was my
second olympic games right so i had
competed in 92 and i had won two matches
and and lost in the third round in
barcelona
i didn't make the podium i lost to a
japanese guy from japan
but the the gold silver and bronze
medalist at that olympics in barcelona
were all guys that i had beat in fact
two of them i was undefeated against in
my entire career the brazilian and the
cuban i had never lost to
so that's when i knew i was capable of
being
you know on the on the podium at the
olympic games when 96 came around i was
25 years old i was fairly in my prime i
had lived in japan for six months my
technique was at a high level
you know i was i was you know amongst
the best in the world
um
i lost at that olympics to a guy from
mongolia it was right before the match i
was supposed to fight against japan so i
was like anticipating the match against
japan and i got beat by the mongolian
so that was kind of a letdown but
the match for the bronze
you know in front of the hometown crowd
all of my family all of my friends
everybody who would ever help me in my
in the sport were in the stands that day
including all my teammates at brown
university that were on the wrestling
team and little
my uncles my aunts everybody everybody
was in the stands right so it was like
the jimmy pedro day
and uh i'm getting goosebumps right now
talking about it
um
but it was a match against the brazilian
for the bronze medal i had beaten the
brazilian like two or three times before
that
um i found myself i found myself down in
the match he actually countered me
um i came in my taotoshi and he was
waiting for it and he counted me and he
scored a yuko against me so i was losing
the fight
came down to about the last minute in
the match and i was just tucking in my
ghee and fixing my thing and gathering
my thoughts together and the whole crowd
just started chanting usa
usa usa and i like literally like got so
much energy i walked out there i grabbed
the guy i came in my talatosh again he
stepped off the taotosh i threw him with
uchimada free pone
i won my first olympic medal in front of
the hometown crowd
everybody went bananas you know the
united states judo team had our first
medal from the olympics it ended up
being the only olympic medal we won one
at that games but it was like a magical
moment to define my career and
solidified myself in like history where
hey and now i get to step up on the
olympic podium and i'm an olympic
medalist and to me that was
my defining moment and after that i was
sold like man i had to go back to the
olympics again i want to win a gold
medal i want to do i want this feeling
all over again i don't care if i have to
wait four years let's let's do it
in your career
the like moments like that
do you think you love
[Music]
winning
or hate losing more
so do you live for those moments
or are you more driven by
just how much you hate losing
so in order to be a champion my belief
is that you have to
hate losing more than you like winning
but i live for those moments when you do
win
and what excited me the most in my
career in my when i was
competing was
i loved being in the finals i love the
spotlight being on me i can't think of
too many times in my career of course
there were a few but there weren't too
many times where the chips were down
like the lights were on and i didn't win
like it was
i might have lost early in the day and
didn't make it to the finals or didn't
make it to the metal rounds but like in
my career i have a ton of golds
i have a ton of bronzes which means
the lights are on
and i won and i have very few silvers
and very few fifths
so i either lost in the early rounds and
didn't make to the middle rounds in my
younger days or
the spotlight came and i really shined
because if you look i i don't know how
many silvers but there wasn't very many
silver medals in my career that i want
you know what i mean so
i just loved that moment i didn't feel
pressure i loved the crowd i loved being
in the spotlight i didn't have i wasn't
nervous when it came to the finals or i
knew i was getting a medal it didn't
matter you know so it was just me
against the other guy and that's how i
always saw it and i just loved that
moment
you